c'est souvent un moment attendu par les
jeunes des clubs la venue de
professionnels le temps d'un mercredi
après midi
cet après midi à ungersheim les jeunes
handballeurs du club étaient émerveillés
et très appliqués quand les joueurs du
mulhouse sud alsace handball sont venus
lors donner quelques conseils à un
moment de partage
avant d'attaquer la montagne le psg en
coupe de france stéphane de narry et
vincent leignel on n'a guère pivot
espagnol et face à lui et ses
coéquipiers 40 enfants de 5 à 11 ans
venue d'une gerstheim et des communes
voisines médiatique est inhabituel pour
les joueurs du mhsa franchement je pense
que c'est plus difficile est légère et
sagaie et même les matchs du psg non et
le oui car en ce moment le quotidien
c'est la préparation du match de coupe
de france contre le psg alors passer
deux heures avec les enfants ça permet
de s'aérer la tête et de couper avec la
muscu et le travail foncier permet de
s'aérer ça permet justement de
rencontrer des jeunes qui sont
passionnés par le handball est justement
ce qu'on ce que nous on a appris en
peuvre on peut leur offrir avec ses
après midi ils passent quasiment toutes
nos journées ensemble à entrer entre
grands à se rentrer dedans à s'entraîner
à travailler physiquement donc c'est
vrai que ça change un petit peu c'est
sympa on passe derrière le plot on est
aux chances d'un côté on revient et pour
les jeunes handballeurs deux heures
d'exercices encadrés par des pros ça
motive et ça impressionne un peu aussi
j'avais peu timide on constatera parler
voilà parce que j'ai pas souvent pour
moi dès qu'ils entrent et moi c'est mon
rêve de toujours voir des professionnels
vous entraînez une orbite très bien
marché on
malheureusement l'un vers ce ne sera
sûrement pas possible en coupe de france
puisque c'est le mhsa qui fera le
déplacement à paris
bon c'est pas non plus une raison pour
se rouler par terre